you've admitted that you're lazy I think
you've read six books in your life I
read six what kind of a woman would be
attracted to you do you think well I had
a lot of money
Sofia Vergara has anyone checked for a
penis
like the these are from the Internet
should be other than yours
I have a phobia of being chased around
with poop on a stick we've all got that
fear what are you afraid of well I was
gonna go with flying but I think I'll go
with girls over 12 do you have any
comments on the Nazi presence at your
protest the presence of Nazis and white
supremacists assaulting people at your
protest you have any comment on that
yeah he has a tractor and he smashes up
old cars just to get attention out of
him did you ever run up to someone and
say hey how did you get so rich and the
woman said by writing on my mom's
coattails and you said Melissa this is
mine right now don't get so [ __ ]
smart Oh Oh we'll apologize for Jones
language right there at the end you're
just trying to be funny with her and she
would do that we apologize trifling
right how many women do you think you've
had sex with do you think more than me
or less than way more than you
[Music]
[Applause]
why should your rights to freedom of
speech Trump a trans person's right not
to be offended because in order to be
able to think you have to risk being
offensive I mean look at the
conversation we're having right now you
know like you're certainly willing to
risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
do that it's being rather uncomfortable
are McDonald god bless you watching your
set was like watching Henry Fonda pick
blueberries
[Applause]
why I don't think there's a person in
here that would not love to watch Henry
find a thick border why don't you just
admit to the public into America that
you got that from listening to me
because that's what I've been saying all
week
well Stephen I'm gonna admit is that you
need the rest of your mustache back
that's what I'm gonna admit okay that's
that's what I'm gonna admit I don't know
I don't know what he did I don't know
what he did I don't know what he did up
there I want you to grow the rest of
that there's too much space in between
here that's the first thing you go in
the water of the ocean alone are you
because people hate ocean I like the
ocean you I do I like the ocean very
much yeah you must do you float a lot in
the ocean
sure what do you think it might be that
cast iron heart and I'm sure I mean I
would hope that if I were a student of
dr. Peterson that he would refer to me
as a as she and wouldn't have a problem
with that but at the end of the day you
know our personal pronoun preference
still is a preference for what language
other people use and at the end of the
day I don't have ultimate control over
what dr. Peterson what the language he
chooses to use or anybody else for that
matters that's that's up to them okay
let me find out then Rises let me find
out if she wants to Deneuve yours what
would you call her she you wouldn't okay
yeah I love lost yeah I lost
yeah I'm obsessed with the show yeah
yeah I'm still watching it I watch it I
wash it on the link though there yeah
you got that working on the computer or
you can watch like one other you could
watch them right after each other right
there's no cliffhanger you know yes you
probably watch it a lot six do you think
I'm 80 I did I watch it during so that
must be an incredibly frustrating no it
wasn't why would you say that well
because because I couldn't wait thirty
Seconds to get into it it's better to
space things out though and discuss it
with your friends have a little they
talk about what happened and then you
wait you have to wait a week and it's
you know it's the way gratification yeah
yes yeah yeah yeah that's what's fun
about a book club y morning after
morning do you sit up in your bed
watching us talk about nothing could it
be because you're addicted to watching
us talk about nothing like so many
viewers are no no I'm addicted to what
are you gonna say wrong next a man that
can be wrong and keep the same straight
things wrong so much Patra dictum so so
many times and look in the camera and
that Blake did how long nine years 180
episode you gave it up right I did they
didn't cancel you you cancel them you're
not aware of this no be honest you think
I got canceled are you under the
impression but I guess I've hurt you
Jerry I thought that was pretty well
documented this is the number one show
on television Larry
Jewish guy okay 75 million viewers well
that's it the big difference between
being canceled and being number one okay
I'm sorry
just imagine a world where I'm George
Clooney that's it no just imagine that
world for a second you're not okay
alright you're asked use your
imagination right now yeah and I know
I'm a guest on your podcast right but
there's no [ __ ] way maybe George
Clooney there you're not in the same
category I think the I just you're not
ugly
you're not ugly but you're not George
like my doctor he said he's not a very
nice guy he said open your mouth and say
oink yeah you need to get better
insurance snort insurance he was calling
me a fat pig well I mean nobody's gonna
disagree with him
oh I'm sorry I've got an acid tongue you
do you're an acid tongue DARAB do you
think Bill Clinton was our first black
president
well I would have to you know
investigate more you know
bills dancing abilities and some of this
other stuff before I accurately judged
whether he was in fact a brother there's
this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board oh all right
do something with that I got the board
it's about Bo re demon I hope I can say
this for insulting you yes you're the
know you know you're the weirdest
looking person on the planet Earth just
nobody I can't describe that that I have
a full head of hair that's what's fine
[Music]
what a perfect transition to Charlie
Sheen because you did his rust at the
height of his whatever you want to call
it meltdown yeah
let's watch
Anthony we're literally watching you
because we couldn't hear a word you said
can you repeat something that you said
about Charlie Sheen I don't even
remember that this is a great operation
you guys are running here by the way say
that I don't know how you screwed that
up someone had hit play if he can
recreate the SVU Donald the Charlie
Sheen thing and we play the video with
no audio yeah go ahead oh go ahead
Charlie Sheen every minute of your life
it's like watching Fox 5 News and it's
completely worthless go see me at the
American comedy company 7 and 9:30 snuck
isn't it work Conan and you went to
Harvard you should know that
snuck past and passed part of me
[Applause]
you wanted a tattoo on your penis I
wanted to put a tattoo if I would get
one there that would said buyer beware
hey I'm impressed there's enough room I
tell you and I can assure you that he
knows there is no no I have this mic on
so yeah that's all right
[Applause]
yeah I can't believe your relationships
don't work
juicing hey I do not wind up with a Tom
kite came from by the way ah derogatory
term I don't know where that came from
where it is when that when people used
to come over on the you know in the
ships that on Ellis Island a lot of
people couldn't write English so he used
to make their mark and the Jews mark was
a circle and the circle is called
Keuchel so that's what they were just
showing it to [ __ ] the guys a here's
another [ __ ] once they've seen the
circle being such a [ __ ] [ __ ] made
someone say the word ragga Tory turns
and where they came from
Wow history really good history your
Christian background is is part of the
the show yes and I wanted to talk to you
about Jesus after well the only reason
why I bring it up as some people thought
maybe you went a little too far you know
as far as what well they thought that
maybe you were being disrespectful to
the Christian religion reason I'm
telling you you need to go go oh good
lord
so did you feel respectful or just you
you were just having fun with some of
the crucifixes and stuff like that I
don't even know what yeah I mean we did
maybe two jokes about that yeah exactly
don't you think the Catholic Church went
a little too far more so than my car too